Hi.
I'm Nicolas Garnier.
I'm a Developer Advocate
for Google Drive.
Today I want to show you how web
applications can integrate
deeply with Google Drive using
the Google Drive SDK.
This will allow your application
to take advantage
of Drive's user-managed storage,
integrate with the
Google Drive online File
Explorer, and potentially
leverage the billions of files
that are currently stored in
users' Drive.
We will demonstrate how to do
that by implementing and
integrating the web-based
text editor.
But first, it is important
to understand what can be
achieved by integrating
your web
application with Google Drive.
So we're going to go through a
few scenarios showcasing how
apps can integrate with
Google Drive today.
Let's now go to Google
Drive File Explorer.
As you probably know, Google
Drive offers a way to
synchronize your files to your
devices and desktop computers.
Our user currently has
a few images stored
in his drive already.
We can see one of them here.
The user now wants to edit that
image, and for that, he
has installed Cloud Paint.
Cloud Paint is a third-party
image editor that offers a
Google Drive integration.
All that the user has to do is
right click on the file and
choose to open it with
Cloud Paint.
The user gets redirected to
the application, and it's
displayed with the image
which he can edit.
Here, let's edit it.
When the user saves the image,
the modified image gets saved
directly on Google Drive.
Here, if we go back to Google
Drive and have a look at the
image, as you can see, we've
got the modified image
directly in Google Drive.
Similarly, we can also create
an image through the Create
Menu with Cloud Paint.
We're going to call
it MrPotato.
Let me do something using my
awesome drawing skills and
click Save.
As you can see in my Drive, the
new file has been created.
Let's just have a look.
And here, we can see MrPotato.
All of that was done
in the cloud.
There was no manual file
manipulation needed.
I didn't have to download the
file from Drive and upload the
file back to the tool.
All that file creation and the
text change were done server
to server using the
Google Drive API.
This is the kind of experience
that Google Drive integrated
application are able to
offer to their users.
So now we're going to see how to
create a Drive application.
For the purpose of this webinar,
we will implement and
integrate a web-based
text editor that
we will call DrEdit.
Prior to coding, there are two
things that you need to do.
First, you need to register
your application.
And then list your
application.
To register your application,
you have to go to the Google
APIs console, create a new
project and enable the Google
Drive API and the Google
Drive SDK.
Then you need to create
OAuth 2.0 credentials.
You would usually have to select
web applications and
provide the URL at which
your app is hosted.
In our case, it's going
to be DrEdit.
Your OAuth 2.0 credentials
are now ready.
You also need to configure
the Google
Drive specific features.
You can do that in the
Drive SDK section.
You'll have to fill in some
information about your
application and provide
some icons.
Most of this is pretty
straightforward.
In this example, I have already
configured my app, but
let me go through a few
of these fields that
need special attention.
The Open URL is the URL to which
we will redirect users
when they open the file
with your app.
You will have to make sure the
Open URL is listed in the
redirect URIs of your
OAuth 2.0 client ID.
This is because we do the
redirect through an OAuth 2.0
flow using the client ID.
And therefore, the URL needs
to be listed as a valid
redirect URI.
You need to list the main types
and the extension that
the app can open.
For our app, we simply listed
the basic text file MIME type
and the TXT extension.
It is usually best to list both
MIME type and extensions.
If your app supports creating
new files, which is the case
for DrEdit, you will need to
specify the URL that will
handle such requests.
Make sure that the URL is also
listed as a valid redirect URI
off your client ID.
Typically, you would need access
to the user's email or
ID, and we will explain
later why.
So we've added the user info
profile scope here.
You don't need to list the
Google Drive API scope as the
Drive that file scope
is implicit.
That default scope gives you
access to Drive files created
by your application or a file
that has been opened through
the Google Drive UI with
your application.
It is important to be aware of
this profile security model.
Now the second thing you need
to do is create a Chrome Web
Store listing.
You need that listing to be able
to install app to some
Drive accounts so that you can
initiate Open and Create file
actions from Drive.
Currently, all Drive apps are
distributed and installable
through the Chrome Web Store.
This is the Chrome Web Store.
In the Developer Dashboard, you
can create a new listing.
This is like creating any other
Chrome Web Store listing
except that you will need to add
two special lines to your
Chrome Web Store apps
manifest file.
You need to specify the Google
Drive container and also your
API console apps ID.
To create your listing, you
will need to include a few
mandatory assets like icon,
screenshots, promo image.
Also, enter a description to
verify that you are the owner
of the website and so on.
To save time, I have already
prepared the Chrome Web Store
listing for DrEdit.
Once these are done, make sure
that you publish your listing
only to a list of trusted
testers while your Drive
application is in development.
This is important so that your
listing does not appear in the
public list of available Drive
apps while not finished.
Once your listing is ready and
published to trusted testers,
just install your app.
And the next time you open
Google Drive in your browser,
you will get a notification
that the app has been
installed, and you will be able
to open supported files
with the app, in our
case, textile.
You will also be able to create
files with the app
through the Create Menu.
So if you choose to create
a file with DrEdit, Drive
initiates an OAuth 2.0 flow.
And since this is the first
time that we are using the
app, we are prompted to
authorize DrEdit for Google
Drive file access and also for
the extra scopes that were
listed in the API's console.
After the user grants access,
he's redirected to your
application Create with URL
where we first need to handle
authorization to the API.
There will be two parameters
passed in the URL.
The first parameter contains
the auth code.
And the second is the state
parameter which contains the
JSON object containing
two attributes.
The first one simply states
which action was triggered on
Drive, in this case, a Create
New File action.
The second is the ID of the
parent folder that was
currently being displayed
in the Drive UI.
This is provided so that the
file created can be saved
directly to the currently
open folder.
So now we need to finish
the OAuth 2.0 flow.
This means exchanging the
auth code for tokens.
In that case, we will
get an access token
and a refresh token.
As you can see here, this is
pretty easy to do using our
client libraries.
After initializing a few static
objects, the extension
is done in one line of code.
In Google OAuth 2.0 protected
APIs, the access token allows
you to use the API
for one hour.
And the refresh token allows you
to extend that by getting
new access tokens.
This is important because you
will need the refresh token if
your application needs to use
the API for more than an hour,
which is the case for DrEdit.
Now, what you need to do is
save this refresh token.
That's basically because we get
a refresh token only the
first time a user opens the
application in Drive.
Subsequent times, the user will
not be prompted for the
OAuth 2.0 green screen, and we
will only get an access token.
So in order to be able to
retrieve the refresh token in
the future, we need to save it
against the ID of the user.
And what we do here is get the
ID of the user through the
UserInfo API.
Alternatively, you could also
use the email of that user,
but the ID is a little
more robust because
it will never change.
We now can save the refresh
token using the user ID
as the table key.
Just use your preferred
database.
For instance, in an App Engine
environment, you could simply
save it to the App Engine
Data Store.
We now have an access token and
a refresh token, which we
just saved.
At that point, we save the
refresh token and the access
token to the session, and
pass the folder ID
as a request parameter.
Then we display the UI of the
web-based text editor.
Let's choose a name for
the new file and
then enter some text.
Let's simply call
it Hello World.
The web-based text
editor using the
sample is called ACE.
ACE is open source, fully
client side, and
JavaScript-based.
To be able to use ACE with
Drive, we simply hooked up
ACE's JavaScript API to some
Ajax call to our back end,
which handles the reading and
writing of Drive files.
So when the Save button is
clicked, what happens is we
send the content of the text
file to our server side code
through an Ajax call.
Server side, we receive the
content of the new file, its
name, description, and the
destination folder ID through
an Ajax call.
Then you simply need these few
lines of code to create the
file on Google Drive using
our client libraries.
There are two parts to a Drive
file, the metadata and the
actual file's content.
We first set some metadata, such
as the file, the name,
the description, MIME type,
and parent folder.
Then in the same request, both
the metadata and the file's
content are sent to the Drive
API to create the file.
Now let's go back to the Drive
Explorer, and as you can see,
the text file that was
just created is here.
Now let's see how to handle the
other integration point,
which is opening an existing
file with your app.
So if we choose to open a Drive
file with DrEdit, again,
Drive will trigger an OAuth 2.0
flow, but your users won't
see the green screen this time
because we have approved the
application earlier.
So all subsequent auth flow
for that app will skip the
approval screen, and you will be
automatically redirected to
the open URL of the app.
Again, there will be two
parameters passed in the URL.
The first parameter contains the
auth code, and the second
contains adjacent
object again.
Still containing two attributes,
the first one
indicates that the
action triggered
on Drive is an open-with.
The second is an array
of IDs of the files
that have been opened.
It is an array because you can
enable a feature that will let
your users open multiple
files with your app,
if you choose so.
Since this is not the first time
the user authorizes the
app, exchanging the code will
only return an access token
and the refresh token.
Now, you have a refresh token
saved in your database from
the first time the
user authorized.
So to get it, you would
typically get the user ID
using the access token to call
the UserInfo API, as we've
seen earlier, and then pull the
refresh token from your
local database using
the user ID.
That way, we can have access to
the API for more than the
expiration period of
the access token,
which is one hour.
Note that all of our client
libraries handle refreshing
the access token automatically
if you passed a refresh token.
Again, we saved the refresh
token and the access token to
the session and passed
the file ID
as a request parameter.
Then we displayed the UI of
the web-based text editor.
Now, the editor queries an Ajax
endpoint on your back end
that will load the files
content, which we
can display in ACE.
So what happens here is that we
have a servlet serving the
Ajax requests that will use
the API to read the file.
After handling the authorization
and initializing
the Drive service, this
is done in two steps.
First, read the files
metadata.
This gives us important info
like the file's name and also
the download URL, which
is where the
file's content is located.
So then we download the file's
content using an authorized
request to the download
URL and return
that to the Ajax call.
Here it is.
The content of the file
is being displayed
client side in the UI.
This is it.
Your app now has basic Google
Drive functionalities.
It can open files from
Drive as well as
create files from Drive.
Don't forget to check
our online
documentation for more details.
You will also find the sources
for the sample application
used in this video.
It is available in
five languages.
Thanks for watching.